à 3-2 à top c'est parti la fraîcheur
automnale n'a pas découragé ces huit
sportifs parmi eux il y as matiz cet
habitué de crossfit en est déjà à sa
troisième séance s'entraîner le matin
c'est ce qu'elle préfère les horaires
sont un peu plus flexible aussi ça
commence à 7h jusqu'à 21h en scène des
sports généralement c'est le soir donc
moi des fois j'aime bien m'entraîner
matin donc pas si l'idéal ouverture de
hors jeu pour une meilleure mobilité sur
les mouvements du bas du corps pendant
le premier confinement jules donner des
cours personnalisés en extérieur pour un
épisode tout si on bat hop je pousse au
keops mais pas facile de transporter
poids et haltères à chaque fois l'idée
du conteneur très en vogue aux
etats-unis a été pour lui une évidence
pour qu'on mettrait pas tous dans un
conteneur en fait on le propose le matin
on la retire le soir ont posé vos
écoutes on avance et on est tombé de
kouba sur ce concept simple et efficace
si on peut retrouver les donateurs de
vous tous le matins comportementale de
sport
des lots rameurs à 20 euros la séance
avec 12 personnes maximum
c'est presque un cours particulier pour
les clients sur le côté tout seul
c'est pas pareil on va dire que tu es
plus vite démotivés t'as plus vite
tendance à lâcher le truc alors que
labatt a pas le choix de faire quoi le
concept séduit en eure-et-loir mais le
coach sportif ne veut pas s'arrêter là
avec son associé benjamin qu'il connaît
depuis le lycée il voit les choses en
grand d'ici à cinq ans cinq à sept ans
on aimerait bien multiplier le nombre de
conteneurs par dix dans le dans le
meilleur des cas où on pourrait proposer
vraiment d'escompter un spécifique aux
entreprises des conteneurs spécifiques
de type box pilate etc et des conteurs
après qu on déplacerait dans différentes
villes aux alentours de la région centre
le duo espère s'implanter en région
parisienne d'ici le mois de février